hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück auf
einem kanal in diesem video zeige ich
euch drei möglichkeiten wie ihr aus
abfall wie zeitungspapier oder
eierkartons ganz einfach und schnell
pflanzt töpfchen für eure gemüsepflanzen
selber was sehen könnt
[Musik]
gerd ist ja ein relativ ökologisches
hobby aber ich bin schon manchmal ganz
schön erstaunt wie viel plastik müller
am ende doch trotzdem zusammenkommen das
fängt bei der jungen pflanzen an sucht
an mit dem ganzen töpfchen die man
braucht dagegen werden wir heute was
unternehmen
dann geht's weiter mit irgendwelchen
bullig folie mit dem ganzen
verpackungsmüll von den sachen die man
kaufen muss um sie im garten zu
verwenden ich bin auf jeden fall immer
relativ ambitioniert das da möglichst
wenig plastiken will bei uns an fällt
ganz ohne kommen wir noch nicht hin
falls das jemand von euch schafft ganz
ohne plastik zu gärtnern lasst mich das
immer gerne unten in den kommentaren
wissen aber so selbstgebasteltes
köpfchen sind auf jeden fall schon mal
ein guter erster schritt nicht nur um
plastik zu sparen sondern auch um geld
zu sparen weil die kosten nicht fangen
wir an mit den klopapierrollen die
schneidest du jetzt einfach mehr an vier
sich gegenüber liegenden stellen jeweils
zwei zentimeter tief ein
[Musik]
dann klickst du die erste der laschen
die so entstanden sind in die mitte
dann die zweite über die erste die
dritte über die zweite die vierte über
die dritte und gleichzeitig unter die
erste so das alles zusammenhält dann
noch einmal kurz flach drücken damit
dass pflanzen stehen kann und dann ist
es auch schon fertig als deine pflanzt
töpfchen ständig umfallen das passiert
manchmal kannst du die mit einem gummi
aneinander fixieren so wie ich das hier
gemacht habe und dann hast du gar keine
probleme mehr mit der standfestigkeit
den test funktioniert dann sehr gut
dann einmal mit anzuchterde fühlen oder
mit kompost ich sehe auch sehr gerne in
reifem kompost aus vor allem stark zu
ihrer viele leute denken immer dass das
nicht geht aber ich habe damit sehr gute
erfahrungen gemacht so lange der kompost
reif ist und dann kannst du auch schon
aussehen
ich habe jetzt zur demonstration erbsen
gesehen die ich normalerweise nicht im
haus vor
aber weil die so schön schnell auf gehen
habe ich das jetzt einfach mal gemacht
[Musik]
angießen und dann heißt es nur noch
warten
[Musik]
für variante nummer zwei brauchst du
zeitungspapier da habe ich einfach mal
eine seite genommen und die in der mitte
gefaltet und jetzt schaue ich mit dem
glas wie gelangen die zeitungsseite sein
sollte dieses glas nämlich als
hilfsmittel um des plans töpfchen zu
basteln da schaue ich jetzt wie weit es
unten übersteht und dementsprechend muss
man da unten dann was abschneiden die
zeitung sollte ungefähr 4 cm länger sein
als dein glas hoch ist so dass du gleich
alle enden in die mitte falten kannst
und das einen schönen boden für dein
pflanzgefäß ergibt bei mir sind das
jetzt hier so ungefähr 8 bis 10 cm durch
abschneiden muss und die schneide die an
der seite ab wo die seiten auseinander
fleddern also nicht an der seite wo der
knick ist perfekt jetzt kommt wieder das
glas ins spiel und ich weg in die
zeitung so um das glas dass sie in zwei
lagen um das glas drumrum gewickelt ist
so ergibt es dann ein sehr stabiles
töpfchen dafür dass man einfach nur
zeitungspapier verwendet hat ist ganz
erstaunlich
[Musik]
der rest wird abgeschnitten dann stellt
man das ganze auf den kopf und knickt
das einmal unten um so dass das einen
boden ergibt und dann noch nicht
abziehen vom glas jetzt musst du nämlich
einmal rundherum gehen und den rand
unten
diese äußere kannte so ein bisschen
zusammen knicken weil das dann den
stabilen boden ergibt
dann kannst du das treppchen abziehen
und es ist fertig
einmal mit erde füllen und dann kann
natürlich auch ein kleines erbsen in das
töpfchen einziehen
[Musik]
und für die dritte möglichkeit brauchst
du einen eierkarton da einfach mal den
deckel abschneiden so wie ich das hier
machen dass ist wirklich die einfachste
methode wie man pflanzt treppchen selber
basteln kann
dafür sind die relativ klein es
funktioniert also nicht für alle gemüse
ja einmal mit kompost oder anzuchterde
fühlen und da kannst du da direkt rein
sehen
[Musik]
nach schön angießen und fertig ungefähr
eine woche bevor ich meine pflänzchen
der nach draußen pflanze fange ich an
die draußen abzuhärten und sie langsam
an wind und wetter zu gewöhnen bei den
klopapierrollen habt ihr zwei
möglichkeiten ihr könnt entweder die
klopapierrolle einmal außen um die
pflanze drumrum abstellen und die
pflanze denn ohne klopapierrolle direkt
in den boden pflanzen oder ihr reist nur
den boden ab dann könnt ihr die pflanze
auch mit dem rest der klopapierrollen
pflanzen und die verrottet dann nach und
nach genau so funktioniert das mit dem
töpfchen die man aus zeitungspapier
selber basteln kann
ich bin immer eher der typ der die
sachen abwickelt weil ich nicht
unbedingt zeitungspapier in deinen
bieten haben möchte aber das würde auch
ohne probleme in deinem beat verrotten
die pflänzchen die in den eierkartons
gewachsen sind kann man auch sehr gut
rausholen und ohne eierkarton pflanzen
dafür einfach einmal unten in den boden
kneifen dann kommt das prinzip
eigentlich ganz gut von selber raus
ansonsten kannst du dir auch ohne
probleme mit dem eierkarton pflanzen der
verrottet auch so schnell dass die
pflanzen sehr gut ihre wurzeln
ausbreiten können und die pappe da nicht
im weg wäre
falls du noch mehr tipps wie man pflanzt
töpfchen selber was sehen kann schreibt
das gerne mal unten in die kommentare
schauen wir auch gerne mal rein ob dann
schon andere leute war es interessant
ist geschrieben haben ich finde es immer
super spannend was da für ein austausch
herrscht und es ist viel schöner wenn
wir uns da gegenseitig weiter helfen
können das seit ich hier die einzige bin
die zu euch rede ich gehe mal davon aus
dass du gerade dabei bist deine
jungpflanzen vorzuziehen deswegen glaube
ich das nicht dieses video da oben sehr
interessieren könnte da spreche ich
nämlich über die häufigsten fehler bei
der jungpflanzen anzucht wenn du einen
pflanzplan brauchst dann verlinke ich
dir meinen fertigen plan gerne unten in
der regio beschreibung dass es ein
fertig ausgeklügelter plan kannst du dir
kostenlos herunterladen und ausdrucken
da musst du dir nicht mehr den kopf
zerbrechen wie das denn genau
funktioniert der anbauplanung
fruchtfolge mischgut wurden was man da
alles beachten muss aber ich habe noch
mehr in petto hier rechts zeige ich dir
nämlich wie du deinen saatgut
organisiert und da unten findest du auch
noch ein spannendes video dann sehen wir
uns hoffentlich gleich wieder biss dann
tschüss
[Musik]